- Welcome back, everybody,
we are here with Hannah
Waddingham, give it up!
- I'm gonna get you,
- [Kelly] Are you ready?
- I'm gonna get ya!
- I love how competitive
you are, I am as well.
- I am.
- Hannah has starred in
musicals like Spamalot
and Into the Woods on
Broadway and West End
'cause she's fabulous.
So in honor of Hannah's musical roots,
it is time to play a round of
Throw Me A Line.
♪ Throw me a line ♪
(audience claps)
- Alright, we need a host.
So here to do the honors,
please welcome a man who you
know from the hit shows Veep,
as well as a man who plays a host actually
in the upcoming
final season of The Marvelous
Mrs. Maisel on Prime Video,
Reid Scott, everybody!
(audience cheers)
(jazz music)
- I mean...
- Uh,
so great.
- What?
- I know, thank you for hosting.
- Thank you for having me.
- [Hannah] What?
- [Kelly] So you played a host, right?
- I did.
- So we just thought
you could nail this.
- I'm coming for your job next. Yeah.
- Okay, great, great, do it, do it.
I give you control of the show.
- I ask for the control.
Well thank you very much.
I'm still-
- I can't believe
that you're presenting this.
- I can't believe...
- [Kelly] It's gonna be great.
- this is kind of a dream, this is so fun.
So here's how the show's gonna work,
I'm gonna read a single
line from a popular song,
the first person to buzz in
and sing the song, including the title
gets the point.
So-
- Including the title, got it.
- So if I say, for example,
"Up above the world so high,
- [All Three] "Like a diamond in the sky."
- You hit the button and you sing...?
(Hannah sputters)
- Tiny twinkle, twinkle, little star!
I was like,
(Kelly screams).
- Twinkle.
(Hannah hits button)
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Everything's gonna go fine.
- Tada!
- Got it.
- Everything's gonna go fine.
So-
- This is gonna be great.
(Hannah laughs)
- And the way we're gonna award it,
so if Hannah gets the point
- [Kelly] Okay.
- The right side of the audience
is gonna win a prize.
- Okay, alright.
- Oh, no!
[Kelly] Alright, alright.
(audience claps)
- You don't sound excited.
- Oh my God, the pressure.
- They don't have faith in you.
- They have no faith in me at all.
- Does this side win if I win?
- And if you win, this
side gets the prize.
- What's up, y'all!
(audience cheers)
Exactly.
♪ Gotta have faith, faith, faith. ♪
Yeah!
I'm ready.
- [Reid] Alright.
(Hannah does raspberry)
(Kelly and Hannah laugh)
- Ready?
- Okay, yes.
- Oh God.
- Are you guys,
you gonna do the hover?
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, hovering.
- Yep, yep, yep, yep.
- [Reid] All right so first line.
- Okay.
[Hannah] Got it.
- So, "Once upon a time
I was falling in love,
Now I'm only fall-"
(Kelly and Hannah hit buttons)
♪ Once upon a time I
was falling in love, ♪
♪ Now I'm only falling apart. ♪
(Kelly gasps)
- That was beautiful!
- Thank you.
♪ Total eclipse of the heart. ♪
- [Reid] That's it.
(bell dings)
- That was amazing,
our harmony's though! Okay!
(audience cheers)
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait--
- It was like under the radar.
- Can they have half
a present for harmony?
(Kelly laughs)
- Half a point for harmony.
- [Reid] Do they get half a point?
Half a point?
- [Kelly and Reid] Half a point!
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] First time we've
ever done it.
- [Reid] I like that.
- Half a point.
Half a point for harmony.
- One to a half.
- I'm actually, I'm gonna award
myself a point for that too
because that is the song that
my high school girlfriend
broke up to me.
- [Hannah] Ohhh!
- Oh my god, are you serious?
- [Reid] With Yeah, she--
(buzzer rings)
(Kelly and Hannah and audience laugh)
Thank you, thank you!
- Wait, did she show you the video
or did she just play you the song?
'Cause the video is kind of amazing.
- She sat me down and said,
"I don't know how to say this,
so just listen to this song."
- No!
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
What a cow.
- What a turd!
- Oh my God.
- I'm glad she's gone.
(Reid laughs)
Well lookie here.
- It all worked out.
- Yeah, yeah.
Pick the weeds.
- Thank you, thank you.
(audience cheers)
This guy gets it.
- Okay.
- Alright, next one.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Here we go.
"My loneliness is killing me
and I must confess,
I still believe."
(Hannah hits buzzer)
- What?
♪ Believe, still believe ♪
(Hannah mumbles lyrics)
♪ Give me a sign ♪
♪ Hit me baby one more time. ♪
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- [Reid] Got it.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Wow.
- In your face!
- Not even the slightest.
I didn't get that at all
(Hannah holds high note)
- Almost like--
- Over my head,
over my head, over my head.
Like not even a little.
(Hannah clears throat)
- Okay, okay,
one to one and a half.
- [Reid] Alright.
(Kelly laughs)
Half.
(audience laughs)
- Next one. This one, I love this song
'cause it's got some of
the weirdest lyrics ever,
but it starts with,
"I'm on the hunt, I'm after you".
(Hannah hits buzzer)
(Hannah mumbles lyrics)
♪ I'm on the hunt ♪
♪ I'm hungry like the wolf. ♪
- [Reid] Yes, yes!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Oh yeah!
(Hannah laughs)
Oh this is worth five, okay,
so this is comeback time.
- Oh my God.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Reid and Kelly] Okay.
"Some day somebody's gonna
make you wanna turn around
(Kelly hits buzzer)
♪ Some day somebody's ♪
♪ Gonna make you want to turn around ♪
(Hannah screams)
♪ And say goodbye. ♪
♪ 'Til then, baby ♪
♪ Are you gonna let 'em hold you down ♪
♪ And make you cry? ♪
♪ Don't you know, don't you know ♪
♪ Things will change ♪
♪ Things'll go your way ♪
♪ If you hold on ♪
(bell dings)
I had to sing the whole thing!
(audience cheers)
- She had a normal day.
- We're in a tie.
- I didn't even say the title!
(Hannah laughs)
I said hold on.
(horn blares)
(Hannah laughs)
- And that lovely sound
means that the game is over
and Kelly is our winner!
- It's so weird how I came in at the end!
(Hannah laughs)
But in our games, it doesn't matter
'cause no one goes home empty-handed,
so Riddle is a female-founded
luxury fragrance, oil, and skincare brand.
(Hannah oohs)
That's vegan,
non-toxic, and cruelty free,
which is awesome.
They offer roll-on
perfumes, spray lotions,
neck-to-toe body oil, and
limited edition candles.
They want their scents to
inspire you to be more confident,
so you're all getting
a three-hundred dollar
gift card to Riddle!
(audience cheers)
Everyone wins!
Not just a half!
The final season of Ted
Lasso is now on Apple TV+.
We'll talk with Reid
about his role on The
Marvelous Mrs. Maisel
when we get back, stay right here.